retrouvez manger ses voté
avec Mutualia la mutuelle des
territoires
[Musique]
bonjour les amis petite promenade
matinale dans les rues tranquilles de
Riquewihr on est sur la route des vins
dans le Haut-Rhin vous l'avez compris
manger ses beautés est en Alsace et on
va à la rencontre du sénateur Ludovic et
du groupe RDP le groupe de la majorité
présidentielle il nous attend pas très
loin d'ici dans les belles collines de
Rixheim
[Musique]
vous m'avait dit je vous retrouverai à
la croisée des chemins il ne m'avait pas
menti bonjour monsieur le sénateur voilà
nous sommes à la banque bonjour Vincent
comment ça va bah écoutez ce serait dur
de pas aller aujourd'hui en Alsace merci
beaucoup sous ce soleil radieux mais il
fait toujours ce temps-là je le dis
toujours c'est vrai je me disais
peut-être c'est parce que vous en êtes
au début de votre vie de sénateur que
vous êtes à la croisée des chemins
encore oui il y a pas mal de chemin
effectivement qui se croisent ça reste
aujourd'hui mon mon point fixe c'est un
lieu dans lequel j'aime me retrouver et
puis bah on est à l'entrée presque ce
qu'on appelle la région des trois
frontières avec la Suisse à proximité à
une quinzaine de kilomètres l'Allemagne
a une dizaine de kilomètres et puis là
nous on est sur cette terre alsacienne
on appelle ça le point triple la zone
des trois frontières aujourd'hui nous
passer la douane changer de langue pour
aller échanger avec nos voisins c'est
quelque chose qu'on fait quotidiennement
c'est vrai que quand des fois on se fait
un monde de l'Europe en disant que
l'Europe elle existe nous si vous voulez
on la vie quotidiennement cette sénateur
c'est un engagement mais c'est pas un
métier vous êtes ingénieur en
cybersécurité progressivement je me suis
occupé de la sûreté des gros système
industriel depuis de la sûreté c'est
passé progressivement à la cyber
sécurité voilà et on comprend pas ou
bien se loger l'engagement politique
là-dedans c'est aussi un état d'esprit
j'ai toujours voulu que les autres
soient bien avant de savoir si moi-même
j'étais bien c'est un peu ma philosophie
vous venez quand même du monde agricole
de votre région Lorraine tout à fait
tout à fait donc vous avez quand même
cette fibre ce pied dans la terre j'ai
une enfance extrêmement heureuse dans
les fermes mon grand-père était
agriculteur et je crois que c'est
essentiel parce que ça vous donne une un
enracinement extrêmement fort sur le
terroir je pense qu'aujourd'hui il faut
pas parler du terroir comme d'un effet
de mode on découvre pas le terroir son
inné on s'y attache et on le défend en
arrivant ici en fait vous êtes retrouvé
dans ce village de Rixheim donc vous
avez été d'abord conseillé municipal et
puis vous avez pris la charge de maire
oui tout à fait alors bon je dois
beaucoup à Olivier best qui est
désormais ministre du Commerce extérieur
et de l'attractivité j'ai rejoint son
équipe 2008 avec le franc parler qui est
le mien je lui dis moi je veux bien te
rejoindre sur la liste exorale si j'ai
quelque chose à faire et il m'a dit ben
écoute avec tes connaissances en
numérique et ce qui a à faire au niveau
de la ville Ville Internet le numérique
dans les écoles et après tout c'est un
petit peu enchaîné olivier est devenu
député
du coup moi je suis devenu mère et puis
les sénateurs qu'il a été peut-être un
petit peu moins prévu
alors vous dites que de votre groupe le
mot le plus important c'est indépendant
on positionnement politique si il faut
en parler derrière il est construit
c'est de l'arithmétique je suis un
scientifique voilà je suis centriste
parce que derrière j'estime qu'une idée
qu'elle soit droite ou de gauche c'est
les bonnes pour les pays il faut
l'appliquer c'est ça qui fait avancer le
pays c'est ça qui fait avancer les
choses ça nécessite une proximité ça
nécessite beaucoup d'échanges avec les
gens je vais beaucoup dans les
associations des fois ils me disent mais
on s'attendait pas ce que sénateur
viennent à notre assemblée générale mais
je dis si parce que derrière moi je
comprends vos besoins je vois comment ça
fonctionne et puis bah c'est une
catégorie en France qu'il faut quand
même bien mettre en avant ce sont les
bénévoles les bénévoles aujourd'hui
tiennent le pays par leur engagement
énorme ce qu'ils font c'est aussi des
personnes qui souhaitent s'investir
au-delà de leur travail ils raccrochent
leur veste ils en décrochent une autre
Ludovic est vous savez que dans manger
c'est voté on s'intéresse avant tout aux
producteurs et aux grands produits des
régions c'est que ici en Alsace c'est
plutôt riche vous m'avez préparé un
programme alors moi j'ai envie de dire
l'Alsace c'est le pays de loi du foie
doigt on va aller voir à marcelet qui
est producteur de foie gras très attaché
au bien-être animal et son foie gras est
juste excellent ah bah moi pour démarrer
la journée c'est parfait
allez on prend la route pour rendre
visite à Marseille et son fameux foi
doit avant d'aller faire la cuisine chez
Isabelle l'école s'appelle épices puis
nous découvrirons les asperges blanches
d'Alsace chez Clarisse le munster
fermier de Matisse pour terminer avec
les vignes du côté du Molenberg dans le
domaine Justin et son Riesling
[Musique]
bonjour Marcel bonjour
enchanté de vous recevoir
votre petite piscine oui c'est une
piscine mais pas pour moi c'est une
piscine des oiseaux à cet endroit
l'endroit il s'appelle James Brown ça
veut dire fontaine de loi ça veut dire
que c'est des champs communaux dans le
temps qu'on mettait à disposition des
paysans pour faire paître des animaux
ici il y avait des oies d'abreuvoir pour
les animaux domestiques les animaux de
la ferme c'est une sorte d'abreuvoir et
vous pouvez voir il coule tout doucement
mais était comme hiver sécheresse ou pas
ça coule toujours on est un petit peu au
démarrage du foie gras d'oie en France
ici on y trace l'histoire depuis l'an
identifier comme étant vraiment un des
berceaux du foie gras d'oie enfin du
travail de Louhans en Alsace du travail
de loi et pourquoi du travail de loi
parce qu'ici à l'époque comme on est
incontour royal il y avait obligation
d'avoir 30 mois grâce à l'époque à
disposition des seniors
avec des oies et pourquoi puisque à
l'époque médiévale tout ce qui volait
était béni et manger le foie des
volailles étaient bénis je trouve que
cet endroit est très émouvant comme
étant un sorte de point de départ qui va
nous mener peut-être en ville parce que
pas beaucoup de fois ici moi je goûter
très bien on y va il y a pas de souci
dites fois doigts
pourquoi oui parce que c'est dans le
traditionnel c'est des fois gras doigts
effectivement mais c'est du foie gras
sans gavage quoi ça veut dire que en
quelque sorte elle se gavent elle-même
sans qu'il forçage alors c'est donc
l'interprétation du mot qui est
importante puisque il y a l'action de
gaver ce qu'on fait normalement et
l'action de ce gaz c'est pas quelque
chose contre c'est quelque chose de plus
un texte de loi qui a été déposé par un
député qui s'appelle monsieur d'ambreval
qui est sur le bureau de l'Assemblée et
nous nous aimerons bien mettre le foie
gras avec ou sans gavage puisqu'au
niveau européen nous sommes les seuls à
ne pas avoir mis un adjectif au mot
gavage nous avons nous attachons un vrai
soutien à nous à nos producteurs à nos
transformateurs de manière à ce qu'ils
puissent produire un produit qui soit
reconnu en tant que tel il y a une vraie
attente de la société sur le bien-être
animal et donc si on peut déguster
d'excellents produits comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui tout en respectant l'animal
on poussera évidemment j'ai eu L214 qui
est venu me voir et le process les
intéresse beaucoup la seule question où
ils vont piéger c'est de me dire vous
les tuer comment c'est effectivement une
grosse question de la bataille
on se doute bien que vous n'attendez pas
qu'il meurt de leur belle-maman et dans
leur prairie on a quelques photos ici on
y est attaché après à ces volailles
ainsi de suite on en mange moins oui je
dirais moins mais mieux c'est à peu près
la question alors sans trahir le secret
du process comment est-ce qu'on donne de
l'appétit aux oies pour qu'elle se gave
elle-même alors je vous donne un exemple
est-ce que par exemple on leur montre le
billet d'avion en leur disant vous allez
migrer bientôt il faut vous nourrir non
c'est pas ça est-ce qu'on fait comme les
beux de Kobe ou les boeufs de Chalosse
où on leur donne par exemple de
l'ensilage de maïs qui a qui va leur
donner de la pétance on est un petit peu
dans l'idée c'est vrai que le bœuf de
Kobe c'est à peu près là où je voudrais
placer mon foie gras de doigt sans
gravage ils font comme moi quand il y a
des bonnes choses on mange quoi donc
voilà et les oies vous leur mettez 5 6
fois et des choses différentes on leur
ramené des kougloops à un moment donné
elles adorent ça je vais ramener des on
en fait d'ailleurs avec mon petit-fils
mais je vous dirai pas toutes les
recettes mais il y en a un paquet et aux
résultats le foie gras parce que ça en
est il est moins gras ils font autant de
gras c'est ce qui les protège d'ailleurs
dans le fond
allez-y dégustez
pas faire la différence avec un foie
gavé si le produit est le même sur le
plan gustatif j'imagine que par ce
process il est un peu plus cher plus de
main d'oeuvre le produit sera plus cher
de l'ordre de 20% par rapport à
la gamme promotionnelle ouais et puis
Marcel on va pouvoir dire à ceux qui
sont vraiment des tenants absolus du
bien-être animal
là vous allez payer un petit peu plus
cher mais vous êtes certain qu'on les
choix aux oies
et on les choix effectivement c'est vrai
et mes papillons aussi merci beaucoup
[Musique]
alors la Vincent c'est difficilement
croyable nous nous situons en plein cœur
du centre-ville de Mulhouse dans un
potager un verger un jardin de plantes
aromatiques nous sommes dans le jardin
potager et d'Isabelle et Berlin et
Berlin un grand nom de la gastronomie
alsacienne évidemment et ce n'est pas un
hasard parce que Isabelle l'épouse de
Marc a souhaité fondé cette école de
cuisine ici nous avons dans les cuisines
pas mal de personnes qui ont connu un
accident de la vie et qui souhaitent se
réinsérer dans le marché de l'emploi et
puis des produits toujours aussi goûteux
et excellents on va voir ça avec
Isabelle
qu'est-ce que vous préparez alors on
prépare une salade de carottes une
recette alsacienne avec de l'oeuf dur
comme faisait les grands-mères Mulhouse
cette réputation d'être multiculturelle
tout à fait beaucoup de population venus
d'origine extrêmement diverses c'est
peut-être le meilleur moyen de cuisiner
ensemble que de réunir tout le monde
bien sûr on pense souvent en moyenne
d'intégration la première valeur qui
nous vient à l'idée c'est effectivement
d'apprendre la langue mais alors
utiliser la cuisine comme moyen
d'intégration on a affaire à une vraie
école de vie on accueille différentes
générations on accueille par exemple
ensemble des publics de personnes âgées
avec des jeunes des bénéficiaires du RSA
avec d'autres publics et du coup il y a
des transmissions des savoirs à travers
la nourriture mais à travers les
rencontres aussi
qui sont favorisés et vous savez bien
que dans la cuisine il faut aussi
respecter des règles c'est une base de
la cuisine on peut pas faire comment la
pâtisserie
un rapport très hiérarchisé dans une
brigade de cuisine ici vous faites
passer le message différemment c'est
vraiment volontaire par exemple quand on
demande à des jeunes qu'est-ce que tu as
réussi aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que tu as
fait au départ il ne savent ils ont
l'impression de n'avoir rien réussi il
ne savent pas ce qui manque des signes
de soi souvent manque d'estime de soi or
quand on a réalisé quelque chose et
qu'on va le servir à des personnes on a
un retour direct enfin il y a une
valorisation
souvent est un peu hors sol et et
l'insertion a besoin d'être ancré dans
la terre et dans le voilà c'est comme ça
qu'on va amener les gens à travailler
les structures de formation ont besoin
d'être en lien avec les employeurs avec
les voilà j'ai même utilisé le service
de d'épices pas plus tard qu'hier soir
voilà je recevais quelques mères et
voilà quand on a la chance d'avoir une
école telle que celle de d'épices et
celle d'Isabelle on essaye tant bien que
mal d'aider au niveau qu'elle neutre
est-ce qu'on peut goûter
moi je le fais pas d'habitude de mettre
mes oeillers dans les carottes mais
maintenant
on va y penser les recettes vraiment
j'ai le sentiment que Ludovic voulait un
petit cours de cuisine particulier moi
je vais aller voir Clarisse pendant ce
temps là les productrices d'asperges
dans la plaine d'Alsace ah oui parce que
la plaine d'Alsace ce n'est pas pour la
choucroute
bonjour Clarisse
un petit peu seul dans ce champ
d'asperges vous êtes pas seul à récolter
quand même un peu de monde le matin mais
on récolte à la fraîche voilà mais je
vous ai gardé quelques asperges pour
vous c'est pour moi c'est pour vous que
c'est gentil des asperges blanches en
plus d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'il y a
une bâche opaque sur le dessus pour
éviter qu'elle ne voyait la lumière dès
qu'elle ne voit la lumière elle prend un
petit peu de couleur et elle devient un
pull vert d'abord
c'est ça donc en fait la vie de
l'asperge blanche c'est buter quoi c'est
buté
a commencé à avoir la lumière elle a une
petite journée de soleil c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'assimilation chlorophylienne
alors voici une gouge
voilà une asperge on la voit on
l'allonge et on la craque
elle nous fait un petit claque et on la
sort
allez-y vous la sortez délicatement
[Rires]
je viens de comprendre un truc là on
vient de passer un petit peu de temps
pour en sortir une bon je suis pas non
plus très doué mais ça veut dire que il
y a pas de machine tout se fait à la
main alors les machines sont en cours de
d'élaboration mais mais on n'a pas
encore trouvé de technique aussi
satisfaisante que la récolte manuelle et
c'est vrai que chaque asperge du social
la main qu'elle soit belle qu'elle soit
grosse qu'elle soit fine c'est un
véritable travail de titan
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour Pauline ça va écoutez
oui ça va je suis assez fasciné parce
que c'est l'illustration de ce qu'on a
vu là-haut dans le champ il y a combien
de calibre différents tout le monde ne
trie pas comme nous on le fait si on
devait compter je pense qu'il y en a au
moins une trentaine non
et du coup même si la saison ne dure que
trois mois
vous le magasin il dure toute l'année on
essaie de garder notre clientèle toute
l'année quoi qu'elle vienne toute
l'année après la saison des asperges et
Pauline transforme énormément de choses
dont les asperges justement quand
on cite les asperges en premier c'est
toujours la vallée de la Durance
souvent la Sologne souvent le Blayais en
région Aquitaine et l'Alsace portant
connaître pas tellement connu au niveau
national tout simplement parce que
l'alsaciens mangent l'asperge locale
90% des asperges produits en Alsace sont
mangés par les aliens et c'est ce qui
fait la force ici ah oui l'Alsacien il
mange de l'asperge alsacienne
attention
donc en quitte la plaine d'Alsace ça
monte tout de suite ah bah là on se
trouve après 1000 mètres d'altitude on
est sur une ferme de montagne la ferme
elle est pensée sauvages qui est tenue
par Mathis Baumann et ses frères et
sœurs également un jeune agriculteur qui
s'est lancé il y a 6 ans donc quand on
parle de succession d'entreprises ou
d'exploitation c'est important de voir
que les jeunes seraient engagent et ça
spécialité c'est la production de Master
fermier au lait cru issu de la fameuse
rasvosienne bonjour bonjour on a été
attiré par les veaux pas montré par vous
c'est vraiment le territoire du fromage
de Munster ici bah oui on a le grand
ballon qui est juste là-bas qui est plus
haut sommet des Vosges donc un moment on
est dans les Hautes-Vosges après le
territoire de Munster est très vaste on
a juste la ville de Munster qui est de
l'autre côté l'autre vallée d'où le nom
et chez nous ça comprend que on est des
paysans qui créent des paysages
je suis plus paysan qu'agriculteur nos
paysans ici sont vraiment des façonnent
le paysage en montagne extrêmement
important on n'y pense pas mais quand on
voit la forêt la tendance à se refermer
et si notre n'est pas les prairies comme
ils le font actuellement prairie de
qualité pour avoir un élevage de qualité
et du lait de qualité c'est toute une
chaîne qui se met en place donc vraiment
moi je l'ai félicite toujours pour ça
j'ai passé surtout une lutte de
sauvegarde de nos valeurs et aussi des
soutiens à nos collègues mais
même ceux qui font moins bien que vous
capte des des agriculteurs qui seraient
moins respectueux de la nature bah pour
moi c'est de pas
défoncer les agriculteurs parce que tout
le monde
mais c'est des accompagner c'est là on
espère sur que tous les sénateurs se
bougent parce que c'est pas tout à fait
le cas encore il faut accompagner les
agriculteurs tout le monde est
convaincre tout le monde est capable de
faire ce que moi je fais en agricole
peut-être pas en montagne mais en bas
c'est et c'est possible et on arrive à
faire vivre du monde on fait du pain du
fromage de chèvre du fromage de vache
des yaourts des fromages blancs la
charcuterie
on propose même des séjours ludiques
s'il faut ici on fait du social on fait
voilà et pour moi c'est ça aussi à la
Confédération paysanne on n'est pas là
pour casser de l'agriculteur mais on est
là pour accompagner des agriculteurs et
les amener à changer de pratique
peut-être un peu à s'éveiller ouais
c'est possible un peu de positif quand
même voilà on peut aller à la fromagerie
bah ouais on va passer par les tables
bien sûr
en plus il fait plus frais
[Musique]
un petit morceau pour toi
excellent mais la planche d'épicéa qui
est là c'est une planche qu'on change
parfois ou on retient des ferments sur
des années
elle peut durer une dizaine d'années
elles sont lavées à chaque fois qu'elles
sont qu'elles ont fait le cycle et elles
se roulaient lavées avec quoi pas
l'autre source et
en fait non frotte avec une brosse
d'accord
les problèmes d'ailleurs on a moins
souvent des problèmes en fermier que les
crues quand
la bonne flore elle prend c'est comme
une bouteille pleine elle prend toute la
place et si on enlève tout cette place
on peut très bien avoir la bonne flore
qui s'installe comme la mauvaise c'est
une mauvaise bactéries c'est un travail
méticuleux sur comprendre la flore
[Musique]
alors là je vous ai amené dans les
vignes de Marie Ghislain qui travaille
en biodynamie c'est un peu leur
spécificité depuis plus de près de 30
ans maintenant et Marie va nous
expliquer en grande partie en quoi ça
consiste et quels sont les cépages qu'il
cultivent sur ces magnifiques coteaux
d'Alsace bonjour Marie merci de nous
accueillir bonjour Marie alors je
comprends que même en vivant ici en
travaillant ici en étant né ici pour
regarder encore cette beauté
on regarde le paysage et en tant que
vigneron paysan on se pose toujours la
question savoir si c'est cohérent donc
la monoculture chez nous c'est pas
cohérent et puis alors on voit partout
dans vos vignes des nichoirs oui nous
avons plus de 300 nichoirs positionnés à
des endroits stratégiques en plus des
arbres et de la forêt nous avons la
chance d'avoir une belle couronne de
forêt c'est pour avoir un insecticide
naturel alors nous avons 13 cépages ici
au domaine et nous avons la chance
d'avoir une des plus vieilles parcelles
d'Alsace 1938 qui est une vraie
compensation de
il se trouve que la complimentation
c'est le système traditionnel de
l'ancien temps en Alsace c'est-à-dire
qu'on mettait sur les mêmes parcelles
des cépages différents Sylvaner resley
Pinot Gris voilà et donc on faisait un
vin avec tous ces raisins mélangés
aujourd'hui on a serré par ces pages
pour une meilleure compréhension du
consommateur final qui va rechercher
plutôt un riesling plutôt assez
tu vois le muscat on l'a mis là parce
que justement il est sensible au froid
donc faire attention ici
vraiment la base de de l'appellation
aussi d'origine protégée ou contrôlée
vous pouvez nous dire la différence
entre bio et biodynamie alors la
biodynamie est un est une culture de du
soin de la terre soit un soin de la
plante on va utiliser un calendrier qui
s'appelle calendrier lunaire des semis
plus la lune quoi on suit la lune en
grande majorités
qui peuvent venir voir ce qui se passe
en cap dans une cuve quand il y a les
coefficients de marée très hauts les
lits qui sont au bas normalement dans le
fond de la cuve sont en suspension quand
on est en marée haute et en marée basse
donc tout est tout va par le sol tout ce
juge aux résultats dans la bouteille
puis dans le verre
[Musique]
c'est que c'est un cépage à sous-sol il
restitue son terroir ce côté très
minéral
[Musique]
surtout en biodynamie encore plus
effectivement on a plus d'influence donc
le climat le micro climat
les vents l'exposition au soleil et bien
sûr notre travail et le travail
avec mon frère Jean-Paul très génération
on souhaite pour les 13 générations
suivantes de continuer à faire ce
travail que vous faites chaque jour et
qui porte ses fruits c'est vraiment
produit prend du temps
à moi de vous emmener au restaurant pour
cette dernière étape alors on va à la
maison Kenny une maison emblématique et
je pense que Mariana doit être à
l'intérieur et bien allons-y
bonjour Marina comment allez-vous
bonjour chef
Emmanuel vallaire
Ludovic je sais pas si vous êtes au
courant mais vous allez bosser ah non
vous l'avez pas dit
chez vous cette volonté de cuisiner
cette fibre voilà
qu'est-ce qu'on va demander à Ludovic de
fer pour la couper en deux comme ça sur
la longueur et après on a posé et couper
des biseau comme ceci on va regarder le
sénateur découper les asperges attention
j'ai la pression attention là je me sens
observé et une petite coupe
longitudinale là on sent le l'esprit
chirurgien tout de suite et ensuite en
biseau faites attention à vos doigts
Ludovic ça m'ennuierait que vous
puissiez plus écrire
chef on va vous laisser travailler je
reconnais pas ce morceau de cochon de
lait c'est quoi alors en fait on a la
poitrine de cochon de lait d'accord on
est venu farcir et rouler comme ça avec
les abats les oreilles les différentes
parts du cochon dites on est quand même
mieux ici que derrière devant le
fourneau ah vous avez pensé à nous un
petit peu
l'Alsacienne merci Marina
vous avez vu cette couleur incroyable
cette robe ici c'est un peu une vitrine
pour l'Europe de l'Est vous avez ce
sentiment d'être la terre accueillante
une terre accueillante sans aucun doute
les Alsaciens portent ça dans leur cœur
l'hospitalité je crois que c'est quelque
chose chez nous qui est extrêmement
important c'est aussi nous qui nous
ouvrons je crois qu'on prend pas
beaucoup de décisions sans consulter nos
voisins allemands nos voisins suisses en
disant voilà quand on prend telle
décision qu'elle est chez vous la
conséquence comment vous vous envisagez
voilà ici dans le Haut-Rhin quels sont
les points clés qu'il faut surveiller
par les points clés sont multiples
aujourd'hui on est mieux d'outils
ailleurs en France c'est la question de
l'eau de la préservation de l'eau on a
une nappe la grande plus grande nappe du
Rhin la plus grande nappe d'Europe sous
nos pieds 35 milliards de mètres cubes
donc pour le coup on n'a pas ce problème
que peuvent connaître les Pyrénées
actuellement je crois que c'est
extrêmement important pour autant pour
autant on a des agriculteurs qui sont
très consciencieux et qui essayent
toujours d'arroser au minimum ce n'est
pas parce qu'on en a sous les pieds
qu'on l'utilise à tout va c'est
extrêmement important où est-ce qu'on
voilà c'est fini ah bah c'est fini c'est
génial on a faim je vous emmène le petit
cochon farci ouh là là l'Alsacienne oh
là là là là là là
chacun son côté hein
c'est très malin quand vous êtes fier
d'être du Haut-Rhin bien sûr je suis
fier tout le temps
et nous aussi on est fier de vous
présenter le meilleur de nos
départements avec nos ambassadeurs que
sont et ces natrices et les sénateurs
d'en manger ces beautés sur le
dictionnaire et vous pouvez retrouver
nos émissions sur la plateforme
publicitaire
[Musique]
c'était manger c'est voter avec Mutualia
la mutuelle des territoires
[Musique]